antes de su asesinato salió una amenaza
firmada supuestamente por los
paramilitares donde salía el nombre de
miller y otros líderes amenazando los
supuestamente por el tema político
electoral posicionarse políticamente le
costó la vida al consejero indígena
miller correa uno de los 12 líderes
sociales asesinados en el departamento
del cauca colombia en lo que va de año
dura muñoz su compañera mantiene el
anhelo de un cambio a las amenazas
constantes da temor
que pueda repetirse la historia
pero pues
es ahí donde yo digo hay que hacer todo
lo posible todo lo que esté en nuestras
manos y más allá en los últimos cuatro
años la deriva para las comunidades
indígenas campesinas afro y
desmovilizados de las farc el incremento
de la violencia en su contra es
observado aún más en las regiones donde
operan los grupos armados respaldados
por el narcotráfico los cultivos
ilícitos la minería ilegal el
acaparamiento de tierras y el abandono
estatal favianca mayo miembro de la
guardia indígena se recupera de un
ataque de las disidencias de las farc
que surgieron después del acuerdo de paz
de 2016 el mismo grupo asesinó a dos de
sus hermanos uno de ellos el popular
líder de la guardia indígena al vídeo
para mayo para el conflicto se agudizó
aún más dentro del territorio en el
gobierno de el presidente buque pues
hace como como un lado deja la dejación
de los acuerdos de para no y creo que es
más donde se incrementa el tema
de los cultivos de uso ilícito se
incrementa el tema de los grupos armados
y referente eso pues también se agudiza
el tema de la muerte de los líderes
sociales pese al dolor su madre evelyn a
mantiene la esperanza de que la paz se
refleje en todas las comunidades los que
votaron los que no votaron pero algunos
comuneros y entonces son unos como forma
de una familia y que toca que mirarse a
todos clemencia carabalí líderes trofeo
feminista con más de una docena de
amenazas en su contra se siente por
primera vez representada en una
candidata surgida de las mismas
violencias que muchas liderezas padecen
a diario el ver que en medio de la labor
tan difícil que hacemos de un contexto
tan complicado
vemos que si se puede escuchar y
trabajar con las voces de los
territorios es lo que exigen al próximo
presidente colombiano estas comunidades
de las regiones más golpeadas por el
perpetuo conflicto armado son parte de
las voces en profundo descontento que
por primera vez en la historia podrían
llevar a un triunfo a la izquierda en
estos comicios